♪ ("SUCCESSION" THEME PLAYING)
Hi, I'm Sarah Snook,
and I play Shiv.
I'm Alan Ruck,
and I play Connor.
(LAUGHS) We're gonna play
together now,
-"Who Said It?"
"Time for a blood sacrifice."
That was Pop.
SHIV ROY:
You think we're through?
Not with the shareholders.
Time for a blood sacrifice.
I gave it away.
(LAUGHS) Well, it--
it was very nicely done.
"I just said,
'I love you, Dad'"...
...ten times in a row.
I think that doubles
my lifetime count.
ALAN RUCK:
I'm-- I vote for Roman.
-When we did--
-SARAH SNOOK: Yeah.
...our little video tributes
to him.
(IN SILLY VOICE)
What up, prick licks?
It's me, Dr. Moron,
and my dad hates all of you.
Fucky go bye-bye!
How was that? Was that good?
"What do you want this to be?
One wedding
and four fucking funerals?"
-Was it you at your wedding?
-SARAH: No.
I got nothin'.
It's about that bear hug letter.
Starting the takeover.
An acceleration.
At-- At my sister's wedding?
Are you insane?
SARAH: It was Kendall and Stewy
planning the Waystar takeover
at Shiv's wedding.
What do you want this to be,
one wedding
and four fucking funerals?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
Nicely done. You whooped
-my ass. Okay.
-Ooh. Okay.
.ALAN: All right.
-SARAH: Okay.
Who said, "If it is to be said,
-so it be."
-"So it be." Yeah.
-Greg, the egg.
-GIL EAVIS: Gregory Hirsch.
Executive assistant
to Tom Wambsgans. Correct?
If it is to be said, so it be--
so it is.
Are you all right?
In episode nine,
in the hearings.
It says 2-10 but it seems to me
it was nine.
Oh, no, it was the beginning
of 2-10, because it--
-Because he had done it--
-It-- We hadn't seen it.
-But we hadn't showed it. Yeah.
-Yeah.
"I look at your face and,
no offense, I see dead babies."
You-- Do you say this? No.
-Yes! It was me.
-Yeah. Yeah!
Yeah, not to Kendall... no.
-No. You--
-You're good. You're good.
-Keep going.
-Yeah.
-You're getting there.
-"I look at your face and,
no offense, I see dead babies."
-Oh! Um, um, Gil.
-ALAN: Wow.
-Yes.
-Gil? Yeah.
I mean, I look at your face and,
no offense,
but I see dead babies.
Connor, he's going to be
the next President.
Really? I just wiped the floor
with him in a debate.
-Oh--
-CONNOR ROY: He was lucky
that wasn't televised.
ALAN: "So, I hereby convene
the meeting of the newly formed
'What the Fuck Are We Gonna Do?'
committee."
-I have no idea, but I'm--
-I'll say it again.
"So, I hereby convene
the meeting of the newly formed
'What the Fuck Are We Gonna Do?'
committee."
That sounds like something
that Gerri would say.
-Ay!
-Hey...
So, I hereby convene
the meeting of the newly formed
"What the Fuck Are We Gonna Do?"
committee.
This is something
to do with the cruise scandal
-coming out?
-Gonna say yes.
-(LAUGHS)
-I'm gonna say yes to everything
you say.
I'm a good guy.
I'm better than you.
We'll fucking beast 'em.
(GRUNTS)
We'll go full fucking beast!
♪ ("SUCCESSION" THEME
PLAYS, CONCLUDES) ♪